devant ici oui c'est sur cette plage des
anses d'arlet que devrait se tenir
la mercury le 29 juillet prochain une
annonce devenu aujourd'hui très officiel
il y aura deux jours de fête le vendredi
28 dans le bourg des anses d'arlet et le
samedi sur cette plage de grande anse et
pour rassurer ceux qui sont inquiets
pour l'environnement des dispositions
ont été prises comme depuis 2013 à
sainte-anne sévices par exemple elles
serviront à amarrer les bateaux pour
éviter que les encres n'abîme les fonds
marins qu'elle ne détruise les herbiers
quel que soit le nombre de bateaux
présents sur la manifestation n'y aura
pas une seule ombre de jeter sur cet
espace tout le long de la manifestation
des équipes de nettoyage qui sont là
sont donc toutes les manifestations et à
la fin de manifestation et vous avez
aussi une équipe de nettoyage qui est
prévu ce qui conduit pas forcément mais
qui est prévue qui a toujours été prévu
cité de manifestations des fonds et puis
il y à d'autres aspects de cette mercury
le côté politico économique pour un
événement comme celui là gilles vajou
rule organisateurs estiment qu'il faut
un maire qui prend ses responsabilités
et c'est visiblement ce qu'il a trouvé
aux anses d'arlet pour que mercury mitch
puisse s'organiser
c'est la condition première c'est qu'il
y ait un élu un maire d'une commune qui
accepte de recevoir l'événement sur sa
commune et il faut en plus de ça que le
meilleur qui nous accompagnent et
vraiment du caractère pour pouvoir
résister aux différentes pressions
médiatiques et autres qui puisse exister
à travers à travers cet événement une
présentation officielle a donc eu lieu
ce matin au centre nautique des anses
d'arlet en présence du maire eugène
larcher
c'est à nous
il faut que cette manifestation devienne
autant plus que sur le plan du
développement économique il faut moins
de booster l'économie a indiqué m et
pour monsieur le maire d installer ce
qui compte c'est faire vivre sa commune
c'est vrai que de ce côté là il y as
lilly add des politiques sont pas du
même bord politique mais qui me
soutiennent et qui me soutiennent il y
en a qui sont du même bord qui ne
soutiennent pas mais y en a qui sont
deux le sont pas du même bord et qui
soutiennent mais c'est une organisation
martiniquaise
il faut mettre tout ensemble que ça
réussisse pour le retour de cette
mercury en martinique la formule sera
donc inédite avec cette friday night
dans le bourg des anses d'arlet le
vendredi soir et une beach à grande-anse
le lendemain le maire des anses d'arlet
a insisté sur un point il sera très à
cheval sur les mesures de sécurité